Paul WS Anderson there are things in
this world worth fighting and dying for
We're warriors it's who we are
Three Musketeers adaptation number 56
Paul WS Anderson director this moment as
you may know his filmography isn't
exactly glowing he directed Mortal
Kombat event horizon soldier Resident
Evil alien vs. predator death race
Resident Evil afterlife and he's
currently filming Resident Evil
retribution quality filmmaking at its
best this film tells the classic story
of the three musketeers again and it's I
don't even really want to get into the
plot because it's essentially just a
rehash of many things we've seen and all
different types of ways except it's told
in the Paul WS Anderson way which is
basically lots of sped up to slow motion
action really quick with horrible
special effects that look really fake
and just absolutely out of this world
independence to be one of you
don't Anya you want to be a musketeer
this is your chance the way he films
special effects it's like he tries to
show you something cool and different
but he films it in such a fake way that
seems like it's in some other dimension
of some kind every single movie he's
made with special effects that I've seen
anyway they all look incredibly fake and
it's not so much that the effects look
bad because the special effects in this
movie actually aren't that bad it's just
he films it so unconvincingly a lot of
the CGI backgrounds and the green-screen
looks really terrible in this movie we
live in a kingdom controlled by fear
cardinal rules the land
rules the skies when new war machines
when we address the balance we have a
young guy who wants to be a musketeer
and his parents train him and like one
scene and then send him off to encounter
life and he meets up with the other
three musketeers and decides to go on
adventures and we have Orlando Bloom and
Milla Jovovich and Mads Mikkelsen I'm
not sure how to say his last name but
he's actually a very good actor and
unfortunately he's lost in this movie he
was the main villain of Casino Royale
he's a very good actor here we have some
of the worst acting however I have seen
here in movies particularly Orlando
Bloom Wow
that man is seriously fortunate to have
been in Lord of the Rings and Pirates of
the Caribbean and virtually the exact
same time because he really can't act
wow he's bad in this movie I mean he's
great as Legolas and he's alright as
will ton but seriously in this movie it
is like the most over-the-top in such
the wrong way wow she's the deadliest
assassin the world has ever seen
together they will unleash war on the
entire continent there are some things
that I can recommend about it's
essentially just the production design
and value of this movie the sets are
very pretty and very well made
constructed a lot of the costumes are
very nice to look at basically the look
of the film ain't that bad it's just
directed in such a boring and you've
seen it all thousand times kind of way
you know what I mean like there's just
nothing special about it it's so
standard so the and the acting my word
the acting is so bad in this movie and
it's so unrealistic through the stuff
that happens is so completely out of
this role unrealistic got two flying
boats at the end fighting with each
other I don't get what's going on
it's just directed so poorly and the
acting and the writing Wow
not good I'm gonna give the three
musketeers adaptation number however
many we've had so far
a d-plus
if you'd like this to be you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuff in
eyes
[Music]